parents enseignants élus étaient
mobilisés ce matin leur crainte perdre
leur statut de réseau d'éducation
prioritaire pour le moment il en
conserve les moyens mais redoute la
rentrée 2010 9 avec la refondation de la
carte scolaire
ici on est quand même dans un quartier
assez particulier un peu défavorisés il
ya beaucoup d'enfants qui ont besoin
d'être soutenus scolairement et que si
on leur enlève ce statut ça va être
encore un grand gâchis et on veut que
nos enfants réussissent nous aussi les
habitants se mobilisent également pour
les enfants du quartier
annie représente le conseil citoyen du
prés saint jean on nous dit il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour les
quartiers il faut il faut que le
quartier prennent une certaine dynamique
et total on s'aperçoit qu'on casse tout
et qui ne passera plus rien à quelques
heures d'un rendez-vous de
l'intersyndicale avec la rectrice les
élus ont souhaité accentuer la pression
il faut que sur un même territoire ayant
les mêmes caractéristiques et vous voyez
que ces écoles sont très voisines elles
sont distantes de quelques mètres et
bien dizaine de mètres et bien il faut
le régime
retenu par le gouvernement de manière
égalitaire sur le territoire le
principal problème et administratif
puisque ces écoles sont rattachés au
collège camille chevalier qui n'est pas
situé en zone rép
une situation qui pourrait ne pas
perdurer en 2019 pour